who I
have can you hear me yeah I have to
change that fact with my face it was
from the coid
period okay so um yeah so uh I will try
to speak a little bit about games
optimization and how Theory can drive a
little bit the thought of uh nowadays uh
development both in industry and
theoretical U multi-agent optimization
so okay let's see a little bit what is
uh uh the background that we have like
if we have been 20 years ago in that
place I don't know if Simons exist but
we will have a discussion about a single
agent that is trying to optimize
function it could be an LP I don't know
what would be but currently the whole
idea that we are trying to tame is that
we are multiple people that we're trying
to solve different problems that we have
our own incentives and uh I think that
you know I should not convince you that
this is what is happening nowadays
because in the majority of the cases the
problems that we're trying to optimize
either they are separated in different
servers or there are sometimes that you
know uh we have multiple agents that are
trying to collaborate to just to solve a
task uh and I mean I strongly believe
that I should not convince you that we
are speaking about the rise of AI driven
multi-agent learning like there are
multiple examples but given the fact
that the half of you you use your GPS in
order to find out the mwell parking uh
so you solve the congestion problem in
order to find your parking today at
morning uh I think I can convince you
that there are multiple cases is where
either explicitly um there are games
that you are playing using AI as an
advice tool and sometimes the problem is
implicit like where in machine learning
many times we're trying to develop like
an architecture that would be like a
game against the uncertainty against the
Privacy that we want to not to leak uh
and so the question is like okay my
claim is the following even if we are 30
years ago MTI agent games were here okay
H what what is the difference the
difference is that now is the period
that we started using AI architecture
for our policy making and now if we're
going back to Theory you will listen
stuff about NP hardness or PP
completeness which means more or less
that there is a complexity class that
says that this problem is difficult but
in practice you park at max parking so
let's uh find out what are the the
hidden structure that we are not
discussing in that worst case
theoretical examples so all these
problems are not just general uh some
problems typically there are problems
that they have some hidden structure my
claim is that in the majority of the
cases we have a convex penalty function
like hinge loss like a squared loss and
the the only idea is that we will
compose uh the the loss of our problem
with the neural net that it is the
advice Machinery in order to take uh our
decisions and that will destroy all the
convexity of our problem and the main
issue is that we have indirect
competition like we do not optimize over
our strategies the only thing that we
can do is like uh optimize our
parameters in our neural net and find
out what would be the result H that the
neural net will have so H to formalize
it even better like good fellow in a
tutorial that gave he said I loved all
these results about equilibrium and
difficulty but all of them H in the main
discussion they are updated directly in
the functional space in practice the
players are represented with deep neural
Nets so we have to understand what is
happening in the parameter space so what
I want to speak about is the idea of
hidden game more or less it is what I
express in that image that typically we
are playing games H most of them they
are monotone convex games so if we were
able to choose over the action space it
would be an easy game the issue is that
the action space is huge so what we are
doing we are doing a function
approximation using a neural ma this is
what we call hidden game this is the
formal definition of what exactly I say
I have a parameter space I have like a a
map this map is typically my neural net
that chooses from the this is the weight
of my neural net and I will take my
action this is what is happening in
practice this is all this amazing
examples that we see from go or any AI
driven gain H the first result that we
had was that yes just gradient send sent
cannot solve this problem actually we
can prove that we have such kind of
recurrencies I say we can prove that we
have such kind of recurrencies not
experimentally
uh very recently we achieved to develop
an algorithm that can solve such kind of
uh non-convex games H but there are
multiple interesting questions in order
to make it applicable in practice like
how you can make it independent and not
a centralized algorithm how you can
parallelize it how you can make it
private for every player and what are
the theoretical guarantees that we can
give that's all thank you very
much
we have time for one question maybe as
the next sets
up